(crowd noises)
- I had no idea what a bar mitzvah was.
And then I saw it and I was like,
“Mama, why didn't you give me one?”
(yelling, cheering)
And now I'm doing bar mitzvahs booked out
three years in advance.
You guys having a good time?
My name is Kareem Wells,
and everybody call me
the King of the Mitzvahs.
(quiet, intense music)
I want to share a part of my heart,
and a part of my life.
When I was 16, I had my first kid.
I was kicked out of high school,
so I did what most people my age did:
I turned to the streets.
I started selling drugs.
I chose that because I felt
like I had no other option.
I grew up on the west side of Chicago
in a neighborhood where
there was a lot of violence,
drug dealing, lot of illegal activity.
This is West Garfield Park,
and this is where my house used to be.
They tore it down, and it's just a lot.
I had dreams, you know, of doing music,
and I loved performing.
The OG's from the neighborhood,
they encouraged me to get out.
They pushed me to follow my dream.
- This guy, we knew he
was going to make it,
and he managed to pull that one off, man,
and I'm proud of the man.
- The thing that the neighborhood gave me
was toughness, and how
to hustle, never give up.
So when I'm out here
doing these bar mitzvahs,
I'm gonna be strong with it.
You know, I’m going to give 200%.
I'm gonna be the best at it.
Everybody here, right?
Hey y'all, let's just meet real quick,
and just talk about what we goin' to do.
The way that I got involved
in the mitzvah business,
I got a call one day from
a half-brother who told me
that there was this party going on,
and he said, "We need a dancer."
So I go over there, and
I see what's going on.
I actually thought it was
a 50th birthday party.
But it turns out that it was
a party for a 13-year-old boy.
Wassup, wassup?
The people saw the way
we was doin' parties,
the way we was bringing the energy,
the way we carried
ourselves with the kids,
ourselves with the family.
It was like, “We gotta get them.”
One! Two!
Come on, clap your hands!
Sing the words!
Yo!
Hey!
Let's go, right here!
Are you ready?
Jump to the beat!
- [All] Everybody!
(techno music)
- Listen, when you walk
into a party that I'm MCing,
you gonna feel the energy the
moment you walk in the room.
And it's gonna be wild,
and crazy, and everybody's
going to be having the time of their life.
We can celebrate.
This about to be a crazy night.
It'll be a memory that
that kid will never forget.
You have some haters that
think it's kind of funny
that a black kid from
the west side of Chicago
is doing bar mitzvahs.
I say to them, “I’m the best in my shoes.”
And I get to experience life at a level
that I never expected I would be.
I never thought in a
million years that I would
be the owner of a entertainment
company for bar mitzvahs.
I am living proof that you
can come from absolutely
some very horrendous circumstances,
and you can make something out of yourself
if you never give up.
The success that this has brought me,
it put me in a peaceful place.
I'm getting paid to make people happy,
to dance and sing, and I just feel great.